bonnier la constitution dans l'esprit de
claude sturni
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
samedi dernier la sncf et l'alsace ont
également connu un drame avec le
déraillement d'une rame tgv testant la
loue la nouvelle ligne grande vitesse
reliant paris à strasbourg sur un pot de
la commune d'aix versailles mme dans ma
cirque lips circonscription tragédie qui
a causé le décès de 11 personnes et une
quarantaine de blessés
j'étais comme madame la ministre
ségolène royal et monsieur le secrétaire
d'état alain vidalis présents sur les
lieux de cette catastrophe et nous avons
été témoins d'une scène de chaos et de
désespoir qui était alors et aujourd'hui
encore inexplicable et incompréhensible
je souhaiterais tout d'abord saluer tous
les services de secours qui ont été
remarquables là aussi et l'efficacité de
la chaîne d'urgence mises en oeuvre
jusque aux hôpitaux de strasbourg et de
haguenau j'adresse aux victimes et aux
familles des cheminots blessé mes plus
sincères condoléances et mes souhaits de
rétablissement
mon intervention comporte plusieurs
questions à ce jour monsieur le premier
ministre
pourriez-vous éclairer la tentation
nationale sur les circonstances exactes
de cet accident et sur les progrès de
l'enquète les français sont légitimement
fiers du succès de leur tgv cet accident
doit donc être expliquée pour ne pas
compromettre son développement et la
confiance des français
nous comptons tous sur une liaison
efficace et compétitive
entre notre capitale du grand est et
paris
quel sur les conséquences de cette
tragédie sur la mise en route de la
deuxième phase de la lgv
enfin je souhaiterais également insisté
sur le maintien nécessaire de la ligne
aérienne paris strasbourg par air france
cette compagnie avait annoncé l'arrêt de
cette ligne en avril 2016 au moment du
lancement commercial de cette deuxième
phase de la lgv sea gens contestent la
logique dans l'absolu je demande que si
la parole est à monsieur alain vidalies
secrétaire d'état
chargé des transports de la mer et de la
pêche merci monsieur le président
monsieur le député effectivement samedi
après midi un accident effroyable ses
produits un tgv qui effectué des essais
sur la future ligne tht entendu du tgv
est a heurté la pile d'un pont
ferroviaire la motrice est tombée dans
un canal et les wagons se sont éclatés
sur des centaines de mètres 11 bord
quarante deux victimes dont deux sont
encore aujourd'hui entre la vie et la
mort le gouvernement partage vos mots je
veux dire ici de notre solidarité et
notre compassion envers les victimes et
envers l'ensemble de la famille
cheminote pour qui c'est un drame
inédit et puis aussi comme vous l'avez
fait fort justement remercié les
services de secours
nous étions sur place avec ségolène
royal à la demande du président de la
république et du premier ministre et
nous avons vu à l'oeuvre
là aussi des pompiers des jambars le
samu tous ceux qui les services publics
tout ce qui finalement sont au rendez
vous dans ces moments là vous poser des
questions et elles sont aussi légitimes
l'accident s'est produit dans une courbe
après la partie nouvelle où le train
faisait des essais à 350 à l'heure il
devait dans cette courbe qui rejoint la
partie la voie historique rouler à 175 à
l'heure nous ne savons pas aujourd'hui
si c'est dû à un accident de vitesse
j'entends ou je lis comme vous des
commentaires personne ne le sait mais
nous aurons les éléments techniques
puisque ce qu'on appelle les boîtes
noires ont été retrouvées
deuxièmement est-ce que cet accident va
entraîner des conséquences probablement
sur la mise en service qui était prévue
le 3 avril mais là aussi pour l'instant
rien n'est définitif et naturellement
aussi sur votre dernière question s'il y
avait un retard cela poserait je pense
effectivement la question de la
poursuite de la liaison aérienne
puisqu'il y avait un lien entre les deux
pour aujourd'hui les mots sont pleines
solidarité transparence et espérance
dans l'avenir si la séance des questions
au gouvernement